not good
thank you for giving me useless chef
there prom
oh I gave myself a shield hey I have a
shield app you jelly
kill everything yeah
shoot the stairs don't stairs can be
dangerous too you know yeah you know how
many people stairs I've killed too
probably maybe we're gonna have saris
some will be lucky my blah blah blah
died in the stairs yeah someone in the
comments like I'm flagging this video
I'm sure a friend right now
you can pretty much die from anything if
you think about it there's a buck up
there
how do I get that teleport you come I'm
a child in my fireball sorry the water
very frost cool
settin up squeeze how do I get I shoot
the Russians no click on that stone its
checkpoints us we've
can I be revived spoon huh click on that
stone
I leave a guy I'm fasting we have a real
how do we all right
w and a w na did I overhear brother
something else will wait for me not
that's not not touch
Copeland's are we against fire I'm a
John in my fire bomb
dude none of me I'll say
great night now you just W and a W a got
your bra look I even here we I'm a child
in my yeah oh wait I hit myself
hey the [ __ ]
how do I I forgot how them
if you want it or not oh it's super bad
why is it so bad I'm not get over there
what is this
but ceiling mice there's something over
for you yes no stop yes that's mine
you got the stone I got this done with
me
how do I don't know I punish people with
a shift oh it's instead of the pistol
look so nice a cool I prefer
go pump
oh no goblins why does it have to be
calm
my job oh we can combine them yes
you're a spider sir
my heir
you spare me right you've been my hair
man
okay you're telling me how sorry
the hue is super bat-o-matic even Harry
was not before
oh I never never used probably because
it sucks
why did you combine water flight
wait you like
egman are you sorry come on dear
I'd rather not kill you and then for
your virus captain be our one except
elevator but it's this
aerolite
nothing
of killing me sometime after anything
now go
charge
oh well either that little poet
no more trolley yeah better for all roll
roll oh no I don't want the captain's
nice I want to freaking no no mics
caliber killer goodbye see bats no you
get a better sword later that's why I
wanna caliber you get on better attack
of the cop and so our young and bold
they wanna say the sit phone on her desk
he's like insolvent magic elementals
injury fear
music working goblins oh no the goblins
it's a vampire kill him
like that
based on camera
thank you a lot
whatever hey Thomas
pistola solar power
no I'm Bank and you're dying to taste I
revived you thank you how do I
wh-what was I what is this what is it
[ __ ] dude Oh dossier
what is this double your egg hello thank
you
you can thank me later
like the place what are you doing
charging up my shield amateur
I owe the shield myself by my own fire
mom come on think
Chardin in that [ __ ] huh you're wet
you spent a night noon
Hey what are you doing here's the stop
shilling I want the killer hearing
okay then oh come on dude oh my god I'm
you I think can you remove the shoe
that's telling me it's a book hair it's
my I'm too good at this game don't you
dare
okay
Hey
oh come here me
Charlie my fireballs
oh dude dude chill up sorry
oh why thank you
really mom
okay I think that's enough now that's
enough that's definitely enough
how are you
why why always always always
[ __ ] [ __ ]
if I'm a [ __ ]